i'm pleased to say the foreign secretary
joining us in the studio is it going to
be a deal or no deal i
i suspect you probably don't have the
answer to that just yet mr i'm good to
see you this morning um
well let's just start with a very
straightforward question where are we as
of half past
eight this morning in terms of those
negotiations well look i called in to
check in with our team at brussels they
worked incredibly hard
you remember the pm has made clear we
want to leave no stone unturned
so we've been at it very hard at the
working technical level if you like
with all the usual jousting of positions
but what really matters
is uh what the eu is willing at a
political level to commit to
there's a conversation that ursula van
der lion the president of the commission
will have with the prime minister later
today
that's when we'll know but i think we
need to be really clear there's two
fundamental issues at stake the issue of
fisheries the issue of the
so-called level playing field we want to
be treated like any other
independent self-respecting democracy if
the eu can accept that at a political
level
then there's every reason to to be
confident but there is still i think a
long way to go
why are they finding it so difficult to
deal with that well i think it's
been difficult i look there's all sorts
of questions around the integrity of the
single market that they talk to
but bottom line is if you ask me and i
i've been at this a while now
indeed i i think the the eu is uh
concerned that actually britain might do
rather well once we leave the eu
and is worried about the competitive
advantage even on the
the normal global rules that apply we'll
we'll talk in a second about those those
sticking points but just in terms of the
chronology of the day
what exactly is going to take place and
when when will that kind of
final conversation take place between
the two leaders
well the exact time is not quite clear
yet but it'll happen later on today
i think it's important it doesn't you
know the the technical talks
matter getting creative solutions uh
understanding each other's positions
really matters
but what ultimately is required at this
11th hour of negotiation
is moving the political log jam that can
only happen
uh at the level of the prime minister
and uh commissioner
van der layne so it is all about the
leaders today it is all about
some injection of political will from
from both of them you see it
look we've been stuck on those two
particular points if the eu
moves substantially and can alleviate
the concerns that we've got about the
way we're being treated not like any
other country
in the world on the eu's own terms that
can't be right we can't accept that the
eu can
find its way to treat us like a normal
independent third country
i think there's every reason to feel
confident but we are not there yet
and and i think that's why that
conversation is so important
is there the opportunity for discussions
to go beyond this evening
if there is a deal to be done we're
hearing you know the prime minister
you know exerting every muscle that he
possesses stretching every sinew
it does rather strike me that if that is
the case then you know you would be open
to continuing talks beyond this evening
well i can't close the door on it but i
think there is
uh a way that the eu's got to go to give
us the reassurance on those two points
of course if we're 99 there on the
outstanding issues
you wouldn't want to leave as i say any
stone unturned but i think it's quite a
high bar
let's talk then about about the level
playing field just explain
do you have a an objection to in
circumstances in which
the european union and the united
kingdom that there was divergence there
was divergence in terms of standards
is your do you have an objection to you
know an increase in tariffs in those
circumstances
just a blanket objection or is it the
unilateral means
by which the european union would be
able to apply those
tariffs as things stand two issues first
of all
are we bound to follow not just uh e
rules
now uh which is uh uh difficult to
accept but also in the future when we
don't know what they were when we
wouldn't have any
say in them where we wouldn't have any
democratic accountability we can't
accept that
um of course uh most uh free trade deals
have global
uh star level playing field commitments
basically political level high level
commitments
that's fine we would accept the ones
that are there for canada we understand
the concerns around that secondly is the
way they're enforced we
presumably i would thought on all sides
want to narrow the issues
if any disputes rise in the future to
preserve the relationship i don't think
you want a nuclear sort of style
uh uh reaction where tariffs go up where
we're back in the same old drama
and soap opera every couple of years or
even sooner than that just because
there's a particular issue around a
particular
sector so i think it's about making sure
we've got a relationship that we can
preserve and nurture
that isn't actually going to continue to
be a thorn in both our sides
so it does seem then at least in terms
of living level playing through
there is a way out of this for both
sides now whether that is
some joint uk eu body or some
independent
arbitrator why have you proved so
resistant to that
well look there's definitely a way out
it's whether there's the political will
on the eu side to accept that we
will not be treated differently from any
other self-respecting
independent economy in the world nor
indeed different from the way that they
would expect to be treated in their
negotiations
so i think it's a pretty high level
political um
commitment but the trouble is for the eu
and we respect
both the integrity of the single market
but also the practical challenges is
they're nervous that the uk actually
could do rather well that we may
actually thrive they're worried about
that as a matter of competitive
advantage
um that's not a grubby thing for them to
be concerned about but of course
we can't pretend that we're not going to
make the very best of brexit but they're
also worried about the message it sends
within the eu we understand those
equities but actually at the end of the
day there is a win-win here
and that's what we're striving for but
if you look at the words of amongst
others mark rutter from the netherlands
i mean he makes it clear that in his
view
it's not just any divergence that would
trigger the imposition of tariffs it has
to be across a ring
it would have to be of a significant a
significant divergence
for anything to kick in i mean they're
not saying that we can't tinker around
the edges but we have to stay
within the broad thrust of of what the
eu's kind of conditions are
well but mark rutter's one voice is
normally pretty pragmatic we're normally
quite close to the dutch on these
matters we've been close allies over the
years but there are plenty of other
voices but the bottom line is this
are we pegged are we required to follow
eu rules past present
future and do we have a situation where
when we're exercising the normal
controls over our own laws
as any democracy does we suddenly find
there's this torpedo of terrorists that
threatens the relationship in the future
doesn't seem to be a particularly
healthy way to go about things
it isn't isn't a really simple fix to
the issue of of phishing and numbers i'm
sorry perhaps not
perhaps not a simple phase but there is
a fix there which is allowing some form
of access to the european union to our
waters
for a limited amount of time i mean the
noises from government seem pretty
positive towards that
yeah but what you're not going to do is
allow a decade to go back to go by
with us only controlling a fraction of
our fisheries i mean look
let's remember on some of these things
some of the proposals some of the
suggestions that have been put to us are
pretty outlandish frankly
they don't get more reasonable by
repetition so what we need is movement
we need some flexibility
actually on the positive side if you
look at the joint committee which was
dealing with the outstanding issues
around northern ireland we've
had some progress this week that's
created not just i think some important
reassurance
around the issue of northern ireland it
gives us a sense actually we can get
there
but we'll need that same flexibility and
pragmatism
on the fta but let's let's talk about
what happens if the
the talks break down and we've had the
prime minister
on a number of occasions talking about
this i just want to show you uh one
quote that he he gave
at the end at the end of last year in
fact
clearly there has been an emphasis on on
getting the trade deal itself
but if we can bring up those words from
uh from boris johnson
this is what he actually has to say um
and it's all to do with
getting a deal can i absolutely
guarantee that we will get a deal
i think i can the possibility you're
alluding to no trade deal
simply will not happen
what went wrong well we agreed the
withdrawal agreement so we got a deal
with the northern ireland protocol
and the eu offered to us written down in
the political declaration
communicated to me way back when when i
was negotiating was that we would
have a free trade deal on the kind of
canada-style terms if we resolved
northern
ireland issues so that was based on oh
we've done that
now we expect to be treated like an
independent third country
we'll take the canada or the south korea
type model of an fta
and frankly the goalpost shifted from
the eu side well you should have been
presumably aware of the fact that that
could happen i think the prime
minister's presume in good faith but
look we
we we couldn't we can't give cast iron
guarantees about
where's we can't give
cast iron guarantees on what the eu will
do but i think if they've said as they
said to me as they said to the prime
minister
if we resolve the northern ireland
issues we agree the withdrawal agreement
then money and things like that the
separation issues
there's a free trade deal canada style
to be done i think we're entitled to say
well we're going to hold you to that
which is all we're doing
surely though the prime minister might
better have said that rather than
can i absolutely guarantee that we will
get a deal i think i can
well i think he was er exuding the
optimism and that confidence
which which he often does which he often
does and he lands him in hot water
like this well and he's showing his
steel and his metal that actually
we're not going to just lie down on two
such important principles but actually
we've gone into this with a spirit
of pragmas and with optimism goodwill
and what we've just found
at the last analysis and at the last
stage the eu has found
letting go of its control over the uk
very difficult i think emotionally
politically if you like
they've got to come to terms with that
it does rather feel that this is the
point at which we are moving from saying
we enter into these negotiations with
good faith to say look it's not our
fault
it's the european union's fault that
you're going to be seeing has come out
of the europe you'll come out without a
trade deal the end of this year
i mean look we're on this we're on the
13th of december at the moment
and businesses still don't know what the
trading conditions are going to be like
in 18 days time 18 days which of course
include christmas and new year well
actually
that's not quite true because a lot of
the approach that they'll need to do
some of the
uh checks will apply in either scenario
we've put in place a border operating
model 700 million pounds going into
supporting
infrastructure extra staff at the border
by march that's a rolling process
the business task force that we've put
in place uh over
i think it's 50 million on things like
customs
intermediaries so that those businesses
that aren't sure how they deal with the
customs aspects and get some support
we've communicated with 80 percent of
smes and yes you're right
there's a difference if we get a deal
that's mainly on the tariff side
um so that yes there will be changes
come what may at the end of january
we've done a pretty good job in order of
just of preparing for it but also
communicating that to those that need to
have that certainty what else is taking
royal navy ships in the channel to
protect our fish
well look uh if i mean this is one of
the ironies if we leave
without a further deal on wto
australia-style terms
the french and others will have zero
access uh
assured to uk waters but that's as we're
trying to get to
we're trying to get a trade deal with
the european union why are the front
pages of some of the right-wing tabloids
carrying headlines about gun boats and
kind of you're raising two digits
towards the continent
well you can better speak to what the
tabloid media may
judge as uh editorially uh fit and
proper but but the bottom line is
actually if we do leave
on wto terms we'll be an independent
coastal state of course
we're going to enforce our waters around
fisheries and whatever else
and of course for the french and others
that will mean you know forget those
outlandish terms that they were asking
us that have
their fishing industries would have zero
access uh guaranteed
can we though not for the for the 17
million plus
who voted for brexit just inject a
degree of honesty and all of this you
know there will be people who voted for
brexit
who will lose their jobs as a result of
a no deal
exit from the european union it's just a
simple statement of fact
and many of them will still continue to
support brexit so
perhaps we'd like to hear from
government ministers this morning
it's just a little bit of contrition you
know what we've got to where we are for
a variety of reasons but you know
ultimately
we have failed we promised that we would
get a trade deal
if it doesn't happen today it doesn't
happen the next few days there has been
a failure by this government and not
achieving it well first of all
as you all would expect i'm making the
case that if the eu would
fooled uh followed through on its
commitments we'd we'd have a free trade
deal it ought to be doable
in relation to our mandate at the last
election we're very clear we've got an
80 strong majority at the last election
um but we do want uh to get a deal if
it's at all possible
equally there are some positives that i
think are all too often
downplayed we've seen recently uh from
netflix to
merck the big pharmaceutical company
investing anew in british headquarters
and british hubs because they've got
that confidence in this country going
forward
and i think if you look at the free
trade deals that we're doing around the
world i'm off to india next week
the growth opportunities over the medium
to long term will all come
i think from the indo-pacific area so
yes we want to fix the european issue
but actually if you look long-term i
think there are huge opportunities i
don't think we should eclipse all of
those
if there is no deal would there be the
possibility
of continuing discussions come the new
year
look i'm not going to uh speculate on
the hypotheticals but what i would say
is this
obviously we're going to be willing to
engage
in a common sense where i think there
would want to be some understanding
about the mitigation so we deal with the
the worst impacts so the course
conversations could continue on that
um but the reality is for the eu their
point of pressure is now
uh after january the first the idea that
they would somehow be able to win
concessions later that they can't win
now i think is
uh is for the birds um i wonder if we
might just talk covert uh for the
remainder of our time together um and of
course there's been a lot of news around
this week so perhaps the
uh the the acknowledgement that we have
got a vaccine out there
in the community perhaps not reported as
as much as it otherwise might and
can we be can we be accurate about how
many facts how many people have been
vaccinated thus far well we um be very
careful
about the numbers because we want to be
accurate and reliable we will uh make
them clear
once we've got them but the first
tranche is eight hundred thousand
we focused on the most elderly nhs key
workers those in care homes
the program is through to the spring
where we hope to be able to move
to a whole better place for the country
in terms of restrictions that we will
have
enough people vaccinated those with high
vulnerability those over the age of 55
key workers uh in order to do that so
that's the rolling phased approach we're
taking but can we
be more specific have there been
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands
i don't have the exact figures now and
we've been quite careful about this
because we want to get it absolutely
right when we publish them but we will
do regularly
i mean do you have them i mean i know
i'm an example of scottish
exceptionalism but the scottish
government
you know were able to produce a figure
earlier this week why can't this
government well
we've only just started the rollout
we're a week in so what we want to just
absolute focus
is getting those uh needles in arms uh
but we have got a process a rolling
process where we can publish
and of course we'll need to track it
very carefully because part of the game
plan to get to spring
is to have enough of the elderly and the
high vulnerability and the key work is
done
so the country can really move into a
place more akin to normal it's a long
marathon between
here and there but actually it's it's
fantastic news we've rolled out the
vaccine indeed a lot of other countries
are not in that position we want to work
with them as well sure but you know if
you invite us all along to point our
cameras at the person who's getting
vaccinated first in the united kingdom
you should probably expect a question
about how many people have been
vaccinated and
i made it clear that our first tranche
and our first role at the first phase of
the roller
is 800 000. and warning
in some of the newspapers this morning
that relaxing the covert restrictions
around christmas for that for that
christmas bubble
could lead to a third wave of
coronavirus in the united kingdom
does the government keep that christmas
window under review is it possible
that christmas might not be on given the
way that infection is going in various
parts of the country
no but it's right to be concerned about
the state of the virus we're not yet
there as i said we've got to bridge to
the spring
and that's why the tiered approach which
is stricter in localized areas than we
had before
is in place and on wednesday there'll be
a review of it against five criteria
hopefully some can come down but if
necessary others can go up the tiered
uh approach but the bottom line is we
must keep control
of the virus keep it coming down i think
just in relation to christmas
it's been a really tough year already
everyone's felt it
i think people do need that five-day
wind over christmas uh to spend a bit of
time with their loved ones and i think
at a mental
health level and emotional level people
do need it that slack over that
it's only a five-day period is built
into all of the other
approaches that we're taking which is
why we've been tougher
more restrictive in the tiered approach
i get that but for a government which
itself describes as guided by the
science i mean if the science is telling
you
that five days of freedom over christmas
will lead to a third wave i just
i just wonder why the option of taking
removing that christmas bubble has been
taken off the table but that's not what
the
scientists have advised us what they
said is if you want to have that
five-day window you've got to be really
careful between now and then
and thereafter that's why we've got the
tiered approach buttressed by
mass community testing which if you look
in say liverpool
you've got the the the posit the the
test the the
um the rate of uh coronal advice down by
i think was around two thirds three
quarters
in fairly short order so we've got the
tools and that does allow us just to
take a little time with our loved ones
uh over christmas yeah well uh i wish
you a very merry christmas when it comes
down
lovely to see you this morning